LELAND: WE’LL CONTINUE TO LISTEN
TO GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK AS HE
HAS AN UPDATE.
AND ON THE LAWN, THE PRESIDENT
HAS SPOKEN BEFORE GOING TO
MARINE ONE.
HE’S IN THE AIR.
AND LISTEN TO THIS AND THEN THE
FLIGHT DOWN TO NOR FORK.
>> IS YOUR TIMELINE OFF THE
TABLE NOW, SIR?
>> NO, WE’RE GOING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
WE WANT TO GET OUR COUNTRY BACK
TO WORK.
THE DOCTORS, NURSES, FIRST
RESPONDERS, EVERYBODY DOING A
PHENOMENAL JOB LIKE THEEN GOOD.
THE COMFORT, THE GREAT SHIP
COMFORT IS STOCKED UP TO THE
GILLS, IT’S RIGHT UP TO THE TOP
AND WE’RE GOING OVER THERE, AND
I GUESS SOME OF YOU ARE COMING
WITH ME, BUT WE’RE GOING TO SEND
THAT UP TO NEW YORK FOUR WEEKS
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
AND IT IS LOADED UP WITH
EVERYTHING.
SO THAT’S GREAT.
I JUST SPOKE WITH GOVERNOR CUOMO
AND HE’S EXPECTING IT ON MONDAY.
IT WILL TAKE ABOUT TWO DAYS SO
WE’RE EXCITED ABOUT THAT, BUT
I’M GOING TO SEE THE PEOPLE THAT
DID THE WORK BECAUSE IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO TAKE A GOOD FOUR
WEEKS AND WE DID IT IN FOUR
DAYS, SO THAT’S PRETTY GOOD.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, HAVE YOU TALK
TO MARK CUBAN ABOUT 3M AND--
>> NO, I THINK THAT 3M HAS DONE
AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
I JUST SPOKE TO KEN LANGONE,
HE’S ON THE BOARD OF 3M, WHAT A
GREAT JOB THEY’VE DONE.
AND I THINK THAT 3M FROM WHAT
EVERYBODY SAID THEY’VE DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, DO YOU THINK
THEY’LL HAVE ENOUGH VENTILATORS.
>> WE’LL HAVE PLENTY.
>> AND IN THE NEXT WEEK OR SO--
>> WE’RE GOING TO USE, I WOULD
SAY WE’LL USE IT AGAIN MAYBE
ONCE OR TWICE, WE HAVE A COUPLE
OF LITTLE PROBLEM CHILDREN AND
WE’LL USE IT WHERE WE HAVE TO.
BUT OVERALL, I TELL YOU, THE
PRIVATE, FREE ENTERPRISE SYSTEM
IS AT WORK LIKE NOBODY’S SEEN IN
A LONG TIME.
>> WHAT KINDS OF SUPPLIES.
>> A BEAUTIFUL THING TO WATCH.
>> WHAT KINDS OF SUPPLIES MIGHT
YOU USE THE DPA TO PRODUCE?
>> WE’LL LOOK AT TWO COMPANIES
THAT HAVE NOT LIVED UP TO WHAT
THEY SAID.
WOULD I SAY THEY’RE IN THE 1%
GROUP, OKAY?
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY HEARD
WE’RE GOING TO USE IT AND
THEY’RE ROLLING OUT THE RED
CARPET.
>> COULD ANYONE WHO LIVES IN A
STATE THAT HAS A GOVERNOR THAT
YOU’RE NOT GETTING ALONG WITH
WELL BE CONCERNED AT ALL?
>> I THINK REALLY MOST OF THE
GOVERNORS ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE
AS I SAID I JUST SPOKE WITH
ANDREW CUOMO AND I JUST SPOKE
WITH RON DESANTIS AND WE’RE
THINKING ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS.
SOME PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
NEW YORK QUARANTINED BECAUSE
IT’S A HOT SPOT.
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY, MAYBE ONE
OR TWO OTHER PLACES, CERTAIN
PARTS OF CONNECTICUT,
QUARANTINED.
I’M THINKING ABOUT THAT RIGHT
NOW.
WE MIGHT NOT HAVE TO DO IT, BUT
THERE’S A POSSIBILITY SOMETIME
TODAY WE’LL DO A QUARANTINE,
SHORT-TERM, TWO WEEKS ON NEW
YORK.
PROBABLY NEW JERSEY, CERTAIN
PARTS OF CONNECTICUT.
>> RESTRICTED TRAVEL FROM THOSE
PLACES?
>> RESTRICT TRAVEL BECAUSE
THEY’RE HAVING PROBLEMS DOWN IN
FLORIDA, A LOT OF NEW YORKERS
GOING DOWN.
WE DON’T WANT THAT.
HEAVILY INFECTED.
WE’RE HAVING A REALLY GOOD
DIALOG WITH GOVERNOR CUOMO.
WE’VE SUPPLIED THEM WITH A LOT
OF THINGS, GIVING THEM AN EXTRA
FOUR MEDICAL CENTERS, TENTS,
THAT’S BEYOND WHAT WE’VE ALREADY
GIVEN.
AND AS YOU KNOW, WE’RE GETTING
UP TO NEW JERSEY, DOING A GREAT
JOB WITH THE GOVERNOR OF NEW
JERSEY, DOING VERY GOOD.
>> WOULD THAT BE A MORE
ENFORCEABLE QUARANTINE, SIR.
>> THIS WOULD BE AN ENFORCEABLE
QUARANTINE.
I’D RATHER NOT DO IT, BUT WE MAY
NEED IT SO I’LL SEE YOU OVER AT